also working now at four a man in
custody in the overdose death of a
teenager a very dangerous issue that's
getting out of hand killing children in
our valley the i-team's david charns is
live outside metro headquarters where
one family is sharing its story david
this family saying this 17-year-old girl
did not know what was in the pill she
was taking they spoke here at metro just
about an hour ago as police make an
arrest for her murder
i went to sleep and i woke up and
everything was gone every day after i go
to check my kids to see are they
breathing today that's what lee gugino
says about his daughter mia a standout
student athlete who died of a fentanyl
overdose in february
metro police saying thursday 22-year-old
joshua roberts provided the 17-year-old
centennial hills graduate with a pill
containing illicit fentanyl that killed
her if you sell a drug and it kills
someone we will be relentless in our
investigation to do everything we can to
take you to justice and if that means
charge you for murder so be it police
tell us the pair knew each other but
aren't saying how what they can tell us
is the synthetic opioid is 50 to 100
times more potent than heroin this photo
showing just how much can cause a fatal
overdose it's already blamed for 144
deaths in the valley this year
four of them children
children and police tell us that simply
the issue is teenagers and young people
are experimenting with drugs and then
drug dealers are just putting all this
stuff in it not knowing what's in it
their message to families at home
tonight just don't do it we're live
outside metro i'm david charns 8 news
now